pomme cette année la présidente du
département du haut-rhin brigitte
klinkert et son homologue allemande se
sont rencontrés afin d'évoquer la
préface hoenheim et le développement
qu'il faut lui donner un avenir qui doit
forcément être franco allemand car cette
fermeture et est une chance pour
dorothée acheteurs ritter et je vous
propose de l'entendre ainsi que la
présidente du département du haut rhin
ne réponde à géraldine derrière et
bernard chemin
la situation de la centrale nucléaire
est enfin clair ça a été difficile c'est
maintenant une opportunité de développer
économiquement dessous ce territoire
s'offre à nous pour en faire un symbole
de l'amitié franco allemande pour
montrer que les gens ici dans cette
région sont capables de construire
ensemble un exemple pour toute l'europe
est face aux picards after 56 europa
il ya deux projets sur lesquels nous
travaillons avec les allemands en
particulier le premier c'est une zone
économique à statut particulier avec un
droit du travail est un droit fiscal
qu'ils soient particuliers à cette zone
donc franco allemand est le deuxième
projet une liaison ferroviaire entre
colmar et fribourg qui permettra de
développer tout ce territoire
et après